shine shine shine
is
only up to you
to get yourself
this room is happy we can make it harder
your health
everybody
shake shake shake
Shake
is a huge stand still to shake shake
shake that's what you make
we are to you
it's only up to you
to get yourself
Thrill Is happy we can make it harder
your health
dance with
me tell everybody's moving to with that
everybody
Shake
is a huge style still to shake shake
shake that's what you make Good Friday
eat until
down
[Music]
I can't get you off my mind
confetti
[Music]
baby
this way yeah
[Music]
yes please
only a mistakes
[Music]
I don't know
shake shake shake
Shake that's what you make good break
eating too enough
[Music]
she will now now
it's only up to you
to get yourself
when everybody
shake shake shake
Shake
stand still
we are to you
it's only
[Music]
good job
okay don't worry about it that was good
thank you yeah
let's go it's perfect dude
[Applause]
[Music]
You Wanna Dance
can I post that online
[Music]
I wrote my YouTube channel on a piece of
paper for him and he's just holding it
up
[Music]
do you dance huh do you dance like
professionally no I'm sorry
to just go around like the like
California what she's going around
California making random people dance
[Music]
oh